thanks T so I'm Jean Ching and I'm like
the also at Google Cambridge office and
I'm one of the authors of tensor flow so
we're going to change topic and talk
about tensor flow so I read your course
material a little bit and I gathered
that you all use tensor flow in previous
parts of the lecture is there right
great
ok so my focus will be how to more
efficiently write and debug machine
learning models in tensor flow so the
question is um whether you need to debug
a machine learning model I think the
answer is yes of course machine learning
models are very different from
traditional programs but they are
software and they're code and if they're
software and code they will have bugs
and you need to debug your models from
time to time so hopefully after this
lecture you will know a little bit more
about how to more efficiently debug your
machine healing models in tensorflow so
before we dive into debugging I want to
talk about how machine learning models
are represented in a computer because
that turns out to be important for how
you write and debug your programs so
there are two ways in which a machine
learning model can be represented so
it's either a data structure or program
so if it's a data structure then when
you write code to for example define a
layer of neural network you're actually
building a graph and those lines of code
when they're executed they don't
actually do the computation they're just
building the graph and the graph means
to be later fed into some kind of
machinery kind of execution engine to
actually run the model and the second
way in which you can define a machine in
a model is to write it as a program so
that's more straightforward so those
lines of lines of code will actually do
the competition on either the CPU or GPU
depending on whether you have a GPU or
not um so the first paradigm is also
called arm symbolic execution or
deferred execution and the second one is
also called eager execution or
imperative execution so now the question
for you is whether tensorflow is the
first paradigm or the second paradigm so
I heard someone said first second both
yeah so I think it's a trick question
right so and the answer is both so if
you ask the question like half a year
ago then the answer will be only the
but in the latest version of tensorflow
we support both modes and I'm going to
give some examples in the following
slides so by default
tensorflow is the first mode so that's
the classical traditional kinds of low
style so just to give you a refresher of
how to use tensorflow to define a simple
model you import tensorflow stf and then
you define some constants or maybe some
variables as inputs and then you write a
line to say like you want to multiply x
MW and you want to add the result of the
multiplication to two another thing B
right so you can think of this as a very
simple linear regression model if you
will now the important thing here is
when this line is executed it's actually
not doing the computation so the
multiplication will not happen at this
point if you print the results of this
line why there you will see it's not 40
it's not 10 times 4 equals 40 instead
it's um it's like a abstract symbolic
thing so it's called a tensor and it
knows what kind of operation it needs to
do when it's actually executed in the
future so mall is that operation it also
needs some information about it also
knows information about like what its
dependencies are which are X and W in
this case but it's not shown in the
printed message here and likewise when
you do a TV ad when that line of code is
executed the addition will not happen is
going to happen later
so by later I mean a case the point at
which you create a session by calling TF
dot session and when TF duck session is
created it will basically automatically
pull in the graph you have already
already built in the previous lines of
code and then you tell the session like
which tensor which abstract symbol in
the graph you want to execute and then
it's going to basically analyze the
structure of the graph sort out all the
dependencies and topple logically
execute all the nodes in the graph to do
the multiplication first and undo the
addition next and then it's going to
give you the final result so which is 42
so you can think of TF da station as a
ng so it's going to run the model on CPU
if you only have a CPU it's going to run
the model on GPU if you have a GPU now
obviously um this paradigm of defining
our motto is not a most
straightforward because those lines of
codes that look like doing competition
is not doing any actual competition and
you need to learn a new API card here
that session so why does tensorflow do
it this way so obviously it's because
there are some advantages you can get so
the first advantage is because the model
is a data structure it's relatively easy
to serialize this and then deserialize
this somewhere else you can train your
model and you can load your model onto
some kind of other devices like mobile
devices or embedded devices like
raspberry pie or car or robot and you
can also serialize the model and then
load the model on like a faster hardware
like Google's TPU
so these things are hard hard to do if
your model is a Python right if your
model has a Python program because those
devices may not have Python and running
on them and even if those devices have
Python running on them that's probably
not what you want to use because python
is slow sometimes so I have those links
here in the slide so I'm going to send
those flies to the course of own answers
and you can click on those links if
you're interested in any of those topics
like deployments on mobile devices and
so on so the next advantage is because
your model is a data structure you are
not tied down to the language in which
the model is defined so nowadays most
machine learning models are written in
Python but maybe your application server
may be a web server is running Java or
C++ and you don't want to really write
the whole stack in in Python just to be
able to add some machine learning to
your stack right so if a model is a data
structure that you can save the model
after training and you can load it into
Java or C++ or C sharp or any of the
some supporting languages and you will
be ready to serve the train model from
your web server or application server
and the other nice thing about
representing data as a the model as a
data structure is you can distribute the
model very easily onto a number of
machines called workers and those
workers will basically use the same
graph and they're going to do the exact
the same competition but they're going
to do it on different slices of the
training data so this kind of training
in a distributed way is very important
for cases in which you need to train
a very large amount of data quickly the
kind of problem that Google sometimes
has to deal with so of course you have
to slightly modify your model graph so
that the shared things like the weights
variables in the model are shared on a
server called parameter server here but
that's basically distributed training
intensive flow in a nutshell
so again if you're interested you can
look at the slide and can click that
link to learn more about distributive
training any questions so far
okay okay so also because you are
representing your model as a data
structure you're not limited by the
speed or the concurrency of the language
in which the model is defined we know
that um python is slow sometimes and
even if you try to make python or
parallel parallel as by writing
multi-threading you will run into the
issue called python global interpreter
lock and that will slow your model down
especially for the kind of competition
that a deep learning model needs to do
so the way in which we solve this
problem in symbolic execution is by
sending the model as a data structure
from the layer of Python into C++ so
there are other layer of C++ you can use
to concurrency you can fully parallel
those things and that can benefits the
speed of the model okay so obviously
there are all those advantages but there
are also those like um shortcomings of
symbolic execution for example it's less
intuitive it's harder to learn so you
need to spend some time getting used to
the idea of you you you're defining our
model first and then run the model later
with TF data session and it's harder to
debug when your model goes wrong that's
because everything every actual
computation happens inside the TF dot
session and that's a single line of
Python code calling out to C++ so you
can't use usual kinds of Python debugger
to debug that but I'm going to show you
that they're actually very good tools
intensive flow that you can use to debug
things that happen in TF that session
and another shortcoming of symbolic
execution is that it's harder to write
control flow structures so by that I
mean structures like looping over a
number of things or if-else branches so
the kind of thing that we encounter
every day in programming languages but
some machine learning models also need
to do that right so like recurrent
neural networks need to loop over things
and some kind of like fancy um dynamic
models need to do if else branches and
so on I'm also going to show some slides
to show those concrete examples so it's
very hard to it's sometimes very hard to
write that kind of control flow
structures in symbolic execution but
it's much easier in ego execution so
with eager execution your program can be
more pythonic and it's easier to learn
and easier to read so here's an example
so on the Left you're seeing the same
code as before so we are using the
default symbolic execution of tensorflow
no now how do we switch to the new eager
execution so you just add two lines of
code you imports the eager module and
then you call a method called enable
eager execution and you don't have to
make any other change to your program in
this case but you will because of these
few lines you changed the semantics of
these two lines multiply and add so now
instead of building a graph this line is
actually doing the multiplication of ten
four and if you print while you will see
the value and if you print a value of Z
you will also see the value so
everything is like a flatter and easier
to understand now as I mentioned before
ego mode also makes it easier to write
control flow dependency and dynamic
models so here's an example so suppose
you want to write a recurrent neural
network which I think you have seen in
previous parts of the lecture before in
in the default mode of tensorflow
here is about the amount of code you
need to write so you cannot use the
default native for loop or while loop in
Python you have to use the tensorflow
special while loop and in order to use
it you have to define two functions one
for the termination condition of the
loop and one for the body of the loop
and then you need to feed those two
functions into in the while loop and get
tensors back and remember those tensors
are not actual values you have to send
those tensors into your session don't
run together
actual data so there are a few hoops to
jump through you know if you want to
write an RNN from scratch in the default
mode of tensorflow
but with execution the things becomes
much simpler so you can use the native
for loop in python
to loop over time steps in the input and
you don't have to worry about those
symbolic tensors or sessions on run the
the the variables you get from this for
loop is the result of the commutation so
eager mode makes it much easier to write
the so-called dynamic models so what do
we mean by static models in the dynamic
models so by static models we mean
models whose structure don't change with
the input data and I think you have seen
examples like that in the image model
sections of this lecture so the guitar
gram here shows the inception model in
tensorflow so the model can be very
complicated can have like hundreds of
layers and it can do can do like a
complicated competition like combination
pooling and dense multiplication and so
on but the structure of the model is
always the same no matter how the image
changes the image always has the same
size and the same color depth but the
model will always compute the same I
mean it will always do the same
competition regardless how the image
changes so that's what we mean by a
static model but there are also models
whose structure change with input data
so the recurrence neural network we have
seen it's actually an example of that
and the reason why it's changes is
because it needs to loop over things so
in the simplest kind of recurrent neural
network it will loop over items in the
sequence like words in a sentence so you
can say that that the length of the
model is proportional to the length of
the input sentence but there are also
more complicated changes of the model
structure with input data so some of the
state-of-the-art
models that deal with natural language
will actually take a parse tree of a
sentence as the input and the structure
of the model will reflect that parse
tree so as we have seen before it's
complicated to write our while loops or
control flow structures in in the
default symbolic mode now if you want to
write that kind of model it gets even
more complicated because there you will
need to nest conditional branches and
the while loops but it's much easier to
write in the ego remote because you can
just use the native for loops and while
loops and if-else statements in Python
so we actually have an example to show
you how to write
model starts take parse trees as input
and the process natural language so
please check that out if you want you
have a question
the tree is static yeah the tree is
static in this particular input but you
can have a longer sentence right it's
the the the grammar of the armed
sentence the parts of the of the
sentence can change from one sentence to
another right so that won't make the
model structure change as well so
basically you can't hard-code the
structure of the model you have to like
look at a parse tree and then like do
some kind of like
if-else statements and wild loops in
order to like turn the parse tree into
the model okay so we have seen that the
eager mode is very good for learning and
debugging and for writing control flow
structures but sometimes you may still
want to debug tensorflow programs
running in the default symbolic mode and
there are a few reasons for that first
you may be using some kind of old code
of tensorflow that hasn't been reported
to you remote yet and some high level
API is you might be using like TF learn
or Kara's or TF slim have not been put
into your mode yet and you may want to
stick to the default symbolic mode
because you care about speed because
eager mode is sometimes slower than then
the default mode so um the good news is
that we have a tool in terms of flow
that can help you like debug attends to
flow model running in the theater um TF
that session in the default mode and
that's always called TF d BG or
tensorflow
debugger so the way in which you you use
it is kind of similar to the way in
which use eager execution we import an
additional module and after you have
created the session object you will wrap
the session object where the wrapper in
this case is called local command line
interface debug wrapper so you don't
need to make any other change to your
code because this wrapped object has the
same interface as the unwrapped object
but basically you can you can think of
this as like an otoscope some kind of
instrument on your TF dart session which
is otherwise opaque so now once you have
wrapped that session when sessions are
run is called your going to drop into
the command line
interface you're going to see basically
a presentation of what
intermediate answers are executed in the
sessions are run and the structure in
the graph and so on so I encourage you
to play with that after the lecture
so the TF debugger is also very useful
for debugging a kind of bugs in your
machine learning models which will
probably occur those are called
numerical instability issues so by that
I mean sometimes values in the network
will become Nan's or infinities so nan
stands R stands for not a number
Nan's and infinities are like bad float
values that will sometimes happen now if
you don't have a specialized tool in
terms of law it can be difficult to
pinpoint the exact node which generates
the lens and infinities
but the debugger has a special command
with which you can run the model until
any nodes in the graph contains an ends
or infinities so in our experience that
happens quite often and the most common
causes of Nan's and infinities are in
the flow and overflow so for example if
there's under flow then a number will
become zero and when you use that number
in division or lock you will get
infinities and overflow can be caused by
learning rates being too high or by some
kind of bad training example that you
haven't sanitized or pre-processed but
under the debugger should help you find
the root cause of that kind of issues
more more quickly so the TF debugger is
a command-line tool it's nice it's low
footprint you can use it if you have
access to a computer only via a terminal
but obviously it's going to be even
nicer if we can debug the tensorflow
models in a graphical user interface so
I'm excited to tell you about a feature
of tensorflow that's upcoming
so it's called tensor board debugger
plugin or visual graphical debugger for
tensorflow so it's not included in the
latest release of
tensorflow which is 1.5 but it's coming
in the next release 1.6 it's available
for preview in Knightley's so you can
copy and paste the code from here
install those nightly builds of
tensorflow and pencil board and you can
use the feature so after you have
installed these packages you can run a
command so all the code in my slides are
copy paste executables
yeah so these are about the main
features of upcoming tool so if you're
interested please copy and paste these
code and try it out this light here is
just a reminder of the main features in
here ok so as a summary we see that
there are two ways to represent machine
learning models intensive flow or in any
deep learning framework either as a as a
data structure or as a program if it's a
data structure then you will get
symbolic execution and symbolic
execution is good for deployment
distribution and optimization and if
it's a program that you will get eager
execution it's good for prototyping
debugging and writing control flow
structures and it's also easier to learn
and the currently tensorflow supports
both modes so you can pick and choose
the best mode for you depending on your
need and we also went over tens of load
debugger both the command line interface
and the browser version which will help
you debug your model more efficiently so
with that I'm going to thank my
colleagues on the Google brain team both
in the Mountain View headquarters and
here in Cambridge Qi and Mahima are the
two collaborators with me on the tensor
board debugger plug-in project and
tensorflow is an open source project
there have been over 1,000 contributors
like you who have arm fixed bugs and
contributed new features so if you see
any interesting things that you can do
feel free to contribute to the tensor
flow on github if it has have questions
please email me and if you see any bugs
or feature requests about tensor flow or
tensor boards you can follow the bugs on
these links thank you very much for your
attention
questions
[Applause]